all right people
this is the reuben report direct message
and this is going to be one of those
days
we pretty much always have one of those
days these days
but this is really going to be one of
those days because obviously the verdict
came in in
louisville yesterday in the brianna
taylor
case and basically all hell is breaking
loose not just in louisville
but unfortunately in many cities
throughout the united states
and i suspect that actually no matter
what
the decision had come out to be that
this would have happened even if they
had indicted all of the officers
there would have been some way to
instigate violence and the people that
are being violent that are right now
uh attacking police officers with
baseball bats which happened yesterday
and randomly shooting into crowds which
happened yesterday and burning down
buildings which happened yesterday and
i'm sure will continue into today
uh they would have found an excuse to do
these things
these are premeditated events um there's
a there's a crazy
video yesterday of a u-haul truck just
being
uh unloaded in louisville and they've
got shields and signs and all these
things like this stuff
is not just spontaneous um
you have to you have to realize that so
obviously i'm going to talk about
the case just a little bit although i
think the case is actually
uh in a weird way less interesting and
important than what it is doing to
society what
what the aftermath is doing to society
which is just an extension of so many
of the things we've been talking about
here um so we're gonna talk about that
uh then secondly we're gonna talk about
the fact that the justice department
has now deemed new york city portland
and seattle
anarchist jurisdictions this sort of
goes to the heart
of this idea that if progressive
run cities if the mayors in these
progressive run cities
if they won't do their job what is their
minimal job i mean you guys know this
what what would someone like me if
you're watching this show
you probably have some ballpark
political philosophy like i do well what
would someone like me
ask the government to do what i ask them
to do a lot would i ask them to take a
lot
from us and then give us a lot in
exchange no i wouldn't i would ask them
basically to do the the minor
stuff not in a way i shouldn't say the
minor stuff i would i would ask them to
do the basic necessity
stuff so for example you got to keep the
roads
clean and safe and paved that would be
nice
you have to make sure that there isn't
crime on the streets you have to make
sure that there's law order things
like that i wouldn't be for giant social
programs but in essence what's happening
here
now the feds are coming in the justice
department and they're saying if you in
new york city will not control your
streets
uh if you in portland will not control
your streets if you in seattle will not
control
your streets your streets and in this
case these are three
fairly far left progressive mayors in
these cities
then we're gonna do it and this creates
a really
interesting tension between
local government and the federal
government and i think it puts people
i would say who are let's say
libertarian or classical liberals
or people who generally don't want the
federal government doing a lot this is
an
odd position for us to be in because
i could see why some people say the more
far
libertarians would say well you voted
these people in let the cities burn
that's it
but then the question is do we have a
duty to our fellow citizens and
you know in many cases these mayors win
with not some
it's not like they're winning with 80 of
the votes sometimes they win with less
than 50 percent of the vote or
or just 51 percent of the vote in which
case should we throw
that 49 percent of people to the wolves
if these people aren't going to do their
jobs i i think there's just an
interesting philosophical debate around
that so i will
uh unpack that as they say a little bit
uh and then third
we're going to talk about joe biden a
little bit and i don't want to belabor
this point i've really
i was thinking last night as we were
going through the stories
you know it sort of like if you're if
you're on twitter
um you can watch clip after clip after
clip after clip of joe biden forgetting
what he's saying
joe biden becoming agitated joe biden
becoming irritated
um saying you know 200 million people
have died instead of 200
000 people have died now look i i talk
for a living
i i screw things up sometimes you know
there's been times
in the history of this show where i've
i've screwed up something
and my guys will say to me after you
know i screw up a number or i screw up a
reference like
things happen sometimes you make
mistakes sometimes you have the wrong
information like it just happens
nobody's perfect right
and in the history of the show there's
been times where i've screwed things up
and my guys
have said to me after you know we should
cut that or
you know we should edit around it you
know whatever it might be
and i basically always i think without
exception i don't think we've ever cut
anything that i've
that i've butchered right um
i always say no we just have to keep it
and then we can make a note in the
youtube comment
section or i can i can correct it or
reference something on twitter
but this biden situation is is getting
worse
and you know as the as the temperature
rises on the national conversation and
as cities continue to burn
and by the way this is what they're
going to continue to do
i mean unfortunately the democratic
party has been left with a seriously
radical base and if and it's not like
all the people burning everything down
it's not like they're all like rah-rah
bernie supporters
uh sorry rob biden supporters there are
no rah-rah biden supporters there there
are none
i mean show me an enthused bite and base
they don't exist what they are
that's why i said bernie is they're
bernie supporters so
bernie was the one bernie and the far
left progressives were the ones
who who were instigating all of this who
were injecting all of this hatred of
america into the system for the last
couple years
and as i mentioned the other day even
pete bootage the most
vanilla nothing you could possibly
imagine in that last debate said bernie
you want to burn it all down and that's
a bad idea
and in an odd way i think the democrats
all knew it
the democrats all knew what was being
fermented right underneath
right and they have no defense mechanism
about this i talked about this a little
bit yesterday
the good liberals have no defense
mechanism about this
they don't they don't know what to do
they don't know what to do
and they're going to watch the whole
country be be destroyed
as they prop up biden as if joe biden
can can stop this thing but the story
that i want to talk about is the fact
that
as of this morning joe biden's campaign
called a lid
on the campaign i i've never heard this
phrase in years past
a lid calling a lid on a campaign but
this is when they announce
that there will be no more public
appearances for the candidate
this is the eighth time the eighth time
that he's done this
this month we are 42 days roughly from
this election
right like it's coming up pretty quick
we're five weeks away five weeks and
change away
and this guy especially on a day like
today
on a day like today when you know he's
gonna the campaign messaging and msnbc
is gonna tell you that
the fascist hitler guy uh is stoking the
flames of all of these cities and the
racial injustice and all this stuff
biden can't even be out there i mean i
am still not convinced he is going to be
the nominee i'm just
i'm just not so anyway those are the
three stories that we're going to do
allow me to have some coffee
you know if you're following me on the
twitter before i get to the first story
i don't recommend you do it because
nobody should be on twitter it's an it's
a self-imposed mental institution
uh however if you are on twitter i i
tweeted out a clip from the golden girls
this morning
there's a wonderful clip of uh of the
three
ladies minus sophia but the three main
ladies dorothy
rose and blanche and dorothy is upset
about something and she doesn't want to
comment before she has her coffee and
something really really funny happens so
you can
take a look it's twitter.comrubenreport
and
the reason i tweeted this morning was
because i was just watching like all
hell break loose on twitter
and like people that i used to respect
fighting with people that i kind of
respect and people who i really dislike
fighting with other people i just like
like everybody's just fighting fighting
fighting fighting fighting
and i was like i need a cup of coffee
before i get involved in this and then
and then like i'm like all right i can
i can calm down you should not tweet
before coffee that's my advice of the
day okay
so let's talk about what happened uh
with this brianna uh
the brianna taylor case so i actually
don't want to get into every bit
of the details about the case because in
many
ways that is secondary to now what is
happening in all of these cities but in
essence none of the police officers
accused
uh were charged in the murder of brianna
taylor
one of the police officers was
was convicted of wanton endangerment for
firing shots that went into another
apartment
now there's a huge debate as to what's
going on with no knock warrants
and why she was shot and the
ex-boyfriend
and there was a drug dealer and a whole
bunch of stuff but i don't think
it's not about this right like it's not
about this the minutia and the little
details of all of these things
let's not forget she was also acquitted
by a jury of her peers it's not as if
the systemically racist system
came in and looked and said here's a
black woman
shot by cops we're going to let her off
like
that's not what happened this was this
was a jury we have a jury
system and it may be imperfect but do
you have a better
option than a jury system i mean there
aren't many better options right like
this is how you
this is how you sort of um unfurl power
from a centralized location so the
government isn't making all these
decisions
uh in effect uh the citizens are making
the decisions with the best information
that they have so the citizens decided
that this was not a murder of brianna
taylor anything that could be
could be charged as such but one officer
his name is brett hankinson
uh he was charged with three counts of
wanton endangerment
uh for firing those shots that went into
another apartment okay so let's
sort of put that part aside i want to
throw quickly
because all of these things there's
there's the original incident right and
then we can debate
whether this happened that happened what
should the
results be and and what the trial should
look like and all that we can do all
that
but then that's very rarely what really
it's all about it then becomes about
burning down cities and trying to
destroy the system and when police have
to get involved and everything else
but if you want to see sort of the level
of craziness that the media has left us
with well first off
uh don lemon was on the don lemon show i
guess it's called on cnn
with chris cuomo and they always have
their very awkward painful
interactions uh it's i think it's at the
end of cuomo show right before they go
into
lemon they have this like minute long
like we're buddies kind of thing
and lemon basically said burn it all
down and then of course now it is
burning it all down so i think the media
the mainstream media has been has been
complicit in a lot of this stuff
but there i want to show you a clip from
msnbc from yesterday because it really
shows
i think and will will shed some light on
when i talk about how
the left is the side that is pushing
racism into our society
that does not mean that there are no
people on the right that are racist but
if you want to talk about where
the system is being injected with racism
and it's a very pernicious racism that's
a little harder to see than the overt
racism of oh i wouldn't want that person
at a water fountain which by the way
there's nobody certainly nobody
mainstream that wants a thought like
that so there's an msnbc clip
and this is former la police department
she's i think she maybe was a detective
she's former lapd
her name's sheryl dorsey and she's
referring to kentucky attorney general
daniel cameron who is black okay
that's an important piece of information
here because you're not going to see him
he is black let's throw to the clip law
is not adequate to respond
to a tragedy that is uh quite a
remarkable
statement a striking statement well
listen not only um
is he being intellectually dishonest
about that you know i find all of his
remarks with regards to
this whole entire press conference
offensive and let me just speak to this
whole celebrity influencer thing
while they can't speak for kentuckians
let me say this is a black woman he does
not speak for black folks he's skin folk
but he is not ken folk and so just like
he thinks they can't speak for kentucky
because he's up there with a black face
he does not speak for all of us this was
not a tragedy
this was a murder he should be ashamed
of himself okay
so we got to dissect that a little bit
because
that man the black attorney general of
kentucky did not behave
in some way that this woman wanted she
decided
that he is skin folk not kinfolk
that is seriously powerful and and and
twisted in many ways meaning he's black
but he ain't black this is that's sort
of an offshoot of a joe biden
line ain't black if you don't vote for
me this is very much in line with
what i hear from uh what i hear about
actually a lot of my friends who happen
to be black and on the right
uh whether it's candace owens or brandon
tatum
or larry elder or someone like thomas
soule or my buddy david webb or the
or the litany of other black people on
the right
the you know the tons now and i think i
think unbelievably emerging numbers of
of black people who now are conservative
or who are trump supporters or whatever
it is
there's this idea that they're uncle
toms they're sellouts
they're skin folk meaning they look
black but they
they're not kinfolk as if as if black is
a ideology not a skin color and that
shows you
how twisted what the left has done is
they've created they've put
skin color above everything else this is
this is seriously dangerous and by the
way it's not just
um skin color that we see why identity
politics is so dangerous
you guys know i've mentioned this many
times before the advocate which was once
i suppose an important gay magazine when
there were actual gay rights to be
fought for
a couple years ago it's about four or
five years ago now they wrote an
article that said that peter thiel
who is who happens to be gay and he
happens to be married and he's a friend
of mine and a very nice guy that he is
not
gay yes he has sex with men he happens
to be married to a dude but he's not gay
because he doesn't identify with the
queer
whatever the hell it is they want him to
identify with so in other words they
will
actually take your sexuality away and
that's very similar
he's skin folk but not kinfolk in
essence we're taking your black away
because you don't think the way we want
you to think and this sort of pernicious
racism
it has almost taken um it has almost
taken complete hold
of the modern left show me a democrat
that stands up against this stuff
please i wish they existed they used to
exist
right they were old school democrats
there were good democrats that came out
of new york
the place that i grew up in there used
to be something called blue dog
democrats what happened to all of these
people
the progressives annihilated anyway uh
we're going to be throwing some clips as
i'm talking right now we're going to
just throw you
some b-roll some video and some clips
of what's going on in various cities
it's not just louisville it's dc
it's new york city it's everywhere else
i mean there are there are police
officers being attacked with bats there
are gunshots
there are i saw a video people throwing
molotov cocktails
all of these things and and the i'm not
showing you this stuff or even talking
about this stuff
to enrage you or to or to scare you
i'm i'm showing it because we have got
to make a decision we are getting to a
fork in the road
in society do we have laws or not
now for the billionth time and everyone
knows this no
system is perfect a system of governance
is created by people
and people are imperfect so we cannot
create a perfect system right
so that doesn't mean that every decision
is correct
okay and if if someone wants if you want
to comment in the youtube comment
section and lay out if you're a legal
expert
what the attorney general got wrong with
the charges what the jury got wrong with
the decision what the police did wrong
if you want to talk about no knock
warrants and all the rest of it
that's that's all well and good and you
should get your voice out there and you
should write an op-ed and all of those
things and by the way those are all
things that you can do
that you can do to affect the system you
can start a non-profit you can work for
a non-profit you i mean
there's all sorts of things that you can
do to to make things better
but that's very different than what the
people in these videos are doing
is any of this making anything better is
burning down a city
and destroying businesses making
anything better
i want you to think of someone that you
know that has a small business
everyone knows somebody that's got a
small business maybe they've got
a restaurant maybe they've got maybe
they're a shoe shiner
maybe whatever it might be maybe they've
got a small
art store whatever it is now imagine
it doesn't matter what your politics are
that that that's the twisted part
that's the twisted part when they're
burning everything down
and by the way uh you know as we saw a
couple days ago after ruth bader
ginsburg
passed away and i showed some some
tweets about it there were plenty of
people
mainstream people saying burn it all
down
burn it all down meaning if mcconnell
goes ahead and
if trump nominates somebody and then
mcconnell brings it to the floor that
you should burn it all down now
first off the burn it all down thing
anyone can burn anything
it's a it's very easy to burn things you
gotta match congratulations you can burn
things building things
is much harder to do and what we are
just the fork in the road that we're
getting to is we're either gonna have to
decide as a nation
that you can peacefully protest i don't
see anyone on the right i mean even the
trump people
i don't see anyone including trump
saying you can't peacefully protest of
course you can peacefully protest go to
a public park
protest where i live here there have
been
peaceful protests at a certain
intersection
for months for months and months and
months there's been peaceful protests
it's just a bunch of young people
standing outside they've got their black
lives matter
signs and all of that stuff you may like
it you may not like it but they're
peaceful and and that's been just fine
and by the way there's a couple police
officers that usually stand somewhat
close by
and i once in a while i'll see people
even going up to them and it's and it's
pleasant and it's actually how democracy
and freedom are supposed to work that is
good
but the fork in the road we're getting
to is if every time
a decision whatever that decision might
be whether it's a decision on a
nominating
a supreme court judge or it's a decision
related to a police incident
and a conviction or a lack of conviction
or whatever
whether it's whether trump signs a
climate accord or not
if the if the policy is that a certain
set of people
are going to burn down cities and then
the the political leadership and the
mainstream media of their side because
this is
all lefty let's let's be very clear
about that all of the things that you're
seeing these aren't trump supporters out
there
these aren't libertarians out there
these aren't conservatives out there
it's just not the case and don't be
confused about that
so the fork in the road is if you think
that just because you don't get what you
want that gives you a right to destroy
someone's small business
to stop people in cars i mean there's
all of these videos
where they just stop people they stop
people in the middle of the road and
i've i've tweeted out some of these
things and then i get these angry
lefties tweeting at me it's free speech
they're allowed to do it your free
speech doesn't mean you can infringe on
other people's rights
imagine you're just driving down the
road you're driving down the road you've
got your kids in the car
and then a mob just ascends around you
what would you do as they're screaming
at you as they've got bats and they're
breaking windows
you'd probably step on the gas and you
might hit people and it wouldn't be your
fault right you don't want to mow people
down intentionally
but you do have a duty to protect
yourself and your family
so we have a we have a decision to make
and by the way i think privately most
people are making the decision
i think privately right now although it
doesn't seem like it because the media
really is
instigating so much of this i think
privately
most people are saying this is crazy
most people are saying we aren't going
to live like this and
i think that they're in the big cities i
think they're going to finally start
voting out some of these
progressive lunatics that are that are
not just instigating it
but but then you know defunding the
police and police can't do this police
can't do that
people want basic law and order you
don't want authoritarian lunacy
but people want basic law and order and
i think we're going to see that i also
think this is why i still think even to
this moment
that that trump is probably going to win
and probably going to win big
because if you're if any if you're
watching these videos if you're just the
average
a political person who might want to go
out to dinner
who might want to walk to the local park
whatever it might be
and you're seeing this stuff and you're
going okay well
the choice is either trump who's saying
something about it who's
who using the national guard when
necessary he's trying to let the cities
uh take care of it but if they don't
then
you know where are we at if your choice
is that or biden who's probably not
going to do anything and and it's sort
of the democrats and
certainly the future democrats um who
are
going to be instigating this stuff um
well then we got a real problem which
brings me to the second story
i'm going along today the white house
has issued a statement from
president trump it is the policy and
purpose
of the united states government to
protect the lives and property
of all people in the united states from
unlawful acts of violence and
destruction
for the past few months several state
and local governments have contributed
to the violence and destruction in their
jurisdictions by failing to enforce the
law
disempowering and significantly
defunding their police departments
and refusing to accept offers of federal
law enforcement
assistance my administration will not
allow
federal tax dollars to fund cities that
allow themselves to deteriorate into
lawless zones
to ensure that federal funds are neither
unduly wasted nor spent in a manner that
directly violates our government's
promise
to protect life liberty and property it
is imperative that the federal
government review the use of federal
funds by jurisdictions
that permit anarchy violence and the
destruction
in american cities that's a pretty
powerful statement and i i
referenced earlier that it creates an
interesting situation it's like okay so
if you see
bad things happening in these
progressive-run cities
now the federal government is supposed
to come in
and fix stuff right if this if the mayor
has lost control of the city or the
mayor's instigating it
uh or you know this buffoon ted wheeler
up in portland who like played footsie
with
antifa for months and months if not
years next thing you know they show up
at his house
at his apartment complex and the guy has
to move so that's the other thing you
can never be
too left you can never be left enough
for these people they'll come to get you
too it's like ted wheeler
the buffoon clown mayor of portland
is not progressive enough he's not he's
not anti-racist enough for you
almost spilled coffee all over the place
there
you see what you've done to me ted
wheeler um
so the question is well then what
does the federal government have to do
as trump laid out there he has
offered federal assistance um and
i think that is the right idea but
here's the question the question really
comes down to this and i and i think you
can make good arguments on both sides i
could see people on the right
let's say you live in a conservative
city somewhere i could see you saying
you know what i don't need any of my
federal tax dollars
going to protect the city that has voted
in all the wrong people with all the
wrong policies like
you could just see that right like that
that's a perfectly sensible thing
and on the other hand it's like well if
the local governments don't do the right
thing then does the federal government
have any responsibility
and my argument would be that if we are
to remain a nation
that that great experiment as dennis
prager calls it
if we are to remain a nation well then
in effect
the federal government does have to do
something so trump in a way is trying a
very moderate measure here he's saying
guys you clean it up you clean it up
otherwise we're not going to give you
funds and then i guess his hope is that
that
there will apply enough pressure because
then the average
person that lives in one of these cities
is going to go wait a minute our funds
are getting cut our cities are burning
down
maybe there's a connection between that
stuff and the people that were voting in
so i think this is an interesting one
i think for those of us that care about
federalism that care about states rights
um this is very much in line with uh
with how we've dealt with coronavirus
which is that you try to give as much
power to the states and then the federal
government
can pick up some of the slack but these
are the type of issues that we're going
to be hearing more and more
about and i think at some level that's
actually good because it does make
make people think where do i want to
live is it in line
with my values whatever they might be
and
if not do i have to move or do i stay
and fight as you guys know i decided to
stay and fight here in la i don't think
it's a lost cause
maybe i'm i'm a dreamer but i'm not the
only one
but you know the the daily wire guys are
going to nashville and i've had some
other friends that that are leaving
um but i can tell you i i meet an awful
lot of good people here in la who have
had it people who are
lifelong democrats who have had it so i
think any kind of surprise can happen
uh ronald reagan he was a hollywood guy
who became the governor of california
and then became the president united
states so so
anything can happen all right let's move
over to the last story which is this uh
biden campaign for the eighth time
this month in september the eighth time
uh has called a lid on his media
appearances this was at about 9
30 a.m this morning now
if you've been listening to me for the
last 20 minutes there's a lot going on
in the country right now there's a lot
of things that a presidential candidate
might want to talk about
might want to be seen to be out in front
of it might
want to try to temper down on some of
the violence might want to
sort of be the leader of his party right
if this guy's trying to be the
president of the united states in effect
he's the leader of the party now
he's the leader of the party more than
hillary clinton more than more than
barack obama
he might want to be out there putting
aside campaigning right
he might want to be campaigning we got
40-something days to the election i
think 42 days of the election you might
want to be campaigning campaigning is
always good if you're trying to win
votes that seems like it would be a good
thing but putting aside campaigning he
might want to just
be out there in a time where there's
chaos because
you know one of the things they
constantly tell you about trump is he's
not a leader he's fanning the flames all
of these things
okay that's that's fine if that's what
you believe um but
if that's the case well wouldn't this be
an incredible opportunity for biden to
be out there
every single day saying whatever it is
that he believes now
i don't know what he believes and i
think in an in an odd way
he needs these riots because it's his
base he can't come out there
and say i am completely against this
because aoc is for this right
uh ilhan omar is for this this the
future of the party is
for this chaos they want to destroy the
system
biden i don't think really wants to
destroy the system but i think biden
also has cognitive problems i don't
think biden realizes
what's coming right behind him i think
they're just sort of using him
and as i've said before i don't think
they thought he was going to break down
that quickly
but but even if he doesn't want to
campaign for whatever reason he doesn't
feel he should be campaigning
and he doesn't want to get ahead of uh
the news right and get ahead of of all
these stories that are breaking and try
to calm everyone down let's say he
doesn't want to do either one of those
things they don't
think either one of those things are are
valuable
at the very least you would think he
wants to be seen because
there is a lot of momentum behind this
idea that something's not right with him
and every single time i say it whether i
have to say it 42 more times once a day
for the next 42 days or whatever it is
i will say i do not take any pleasure in
that there is something wrong with him
and the scandal is the non-scandal
please
show ask your if you're abide in
supporter
you're a democrat or you just know a
democrat ask
anyone who's supporting biden no matter
how much they hate trump
do you think biden is all there do you
think
that he is fit to be president and i
can't find anyone that'll fully say it
they'll give you some uncomfortable
choked out answer but i keep tweeting it
out can i get somebody can i get some
blue check verified somebody with
with a decent following to say that they
don't think anything's wrong with biden
so it's almost as if the campaign is
like
all right we're not going to campaign
we're not going to get ahead of the news
and we're not even going to just put him
out there
so he can just talk so that it might
um break up some of these ideas that
something's not right with the guy so i
i just don't know what they're doing
over there
and 50 50. that's what i would tell you
guys i think it's i think it's 50 50
as to as to whether he's the nominee or
not i know that's crazy
and what a what a strange world we live
in and it's like we don't need that
you know with the with the supreme court
nominee coming right trump's going to
nominate somebody
i think on saturday and then we'll go
into we'll go into the next steps on
that and then the election coming and
and the riots and everything else like
we don't need biden to step down and yet
i think 50 50. i just think it's 50 50.
all right
all of this being said i know this was
uh it could be a little overwhelming and
it could feel crazy get offline when you
can
step outside take a walk um say hi to a
neighbor
i'll just give you one other little what
a little piece of human advice we moved
i've been saying hi to my neighbors left
and right a lot of nice people
i don't know their politics i hope they
don't know my politics
if that's a problem i hope they don't
know my politics if it's a problem for
them
but but there's good people out there it
gets hard to see
sometimes but but find them and
and i think we're gonna be okay one way
or another
that is the direct message i'll see you
guys
on wait today's today's thursday i'll
see you on tuesday
all right later